the final three to nothing the story in
this one this man right here Joey dord
35 save shut
out Joey Joey Joey Joey Joey
Joy that's amazing that's got to be the
coolest just onet yeah I mean this is
the coolest thing that's ever happened
in my whole life and uh couldn't be
grateful uh more grateful for you guys
you guys were unbelievable today thank
you guys so much and uh glad we got a
huge win for you
guys it's been a a wild ride for you um
four years in the NHL you played 19
games and you get 23 games this season
but you're a big part of this run that
this team is on right now what does this
feel like and I know the ad agulation
here is great but in that first period
you make a save and this place erupts uh
yeah I mean it's hard to describe um you
know the the support that I've gotten so
far this year and um you know it's
pretty cool at climate pledge when I get
the Joey chance but this was something
else uh you know four or five times more
people here and um it was amazing and um
you know in regards to the Run we've
been on I think you can just you just
look at the way we played today they
they really made my life easy the boys L
unbelievable um some amazing sticks and
and Big Blocks and just selling out for
the team and um you know this run we've
been on as a group has been awesome and
um you know I think it's it's a
collective effort from all of us uh
you've dealt with your fair share of
adversity through your career I was was
actually talking with your ASU coach
Greg Powers he said your first ever
start in college I think you got shelled
for nine goals in your first two periods
at nor Dame and he came up to you and he
said you know do you want to be pulled
and you said f no and that's just kind
of the mentality you have and then
obviously two years later you lead ASU
to their first ever tournament uh
tournament bid and and I mean just talk
about the the the entire time through
ASU and what you've dealt with in your
career and what has gotten you to this
point well uh coach Powers has never
exaggerated in his life so uh that's a
bang on story um no I was nine in the
whole game not just the first okay sorry
about that yeah they went uh three for
seven on five on three power plays so
was a tough one um but uh yeah I mean I
just think about you know uh the journey
that it's been for myself and um all of
the incredible people that it's taken
for me to get here I mean um you know it
truly takes a village of people um and
you know I'm so grateful I was able to
share today with you know my family my
girlfriend um her family all my best
friends are here from home and um you
know I'm I'm so excited to go see them
right now and um you know all the
amazing coaches and people and um
teammates that I've had and mentors and
um I'm just so grateful for the
opportunity to be here playing in the
NHL this is um the most amazing special
thing um you could ever dream of and um
when I was a kid all I wanted to do was
play in the NHL and I mean there's no
bigger stage in this and um you know I'm
pretty emotional right now was
absolutely amazing today it's awesome
Joey unbelievable game today
unbelievable game fans here in Seattle
love you the goalie mask is so unique to
each individual go tender you have yours
here on set with us today can you kind
of walk us through what you have on here
and why is it so special to you well I'm
a huge sports fan um they grew up a
Boston kid and obviously uh Sports in
Boston's huge and um you know definitely
uh adopted the uh the Seattle sports
teams as well now and um I thought no
better opportunity um than to put some
Mariners you know uh themed stuff on
here been playing at T-Mobile Park and
um you know I've come to a bunch of
games and I'm a big fan of this team
here as well and um you know got some of
the guys the baseball cards on here we
got JP Crawford Cal Raleigh J Rod um you
know great players and um on the other
side here we got uh Ken griffy and
Ichiro and Edgar Martinez so some of the
Legends um yeah it's just an awesome
opportunity to get to do something you
know extra fun with my mask it came out
unbelievable my mask painter did an
incredible job I'm not sure people
realize there's a difference between
indoor and outdoor the lighting was it a
good thing you got a practice in
yesterday to get your eyes adjusted to
the different kind of lighting that we
have here absolutely yeah um yesterday I
was just working on pucks above the
glass honestly today was still really
tricky anything above the white above
the boards was really hard um I'm
thankful there was no sun in my
eyes for maybe some team people counting
this team out especially early in the
season the way things started what do
you have to say about the group in that
locker room and what you think you guys
can do in the second half of the season
to ignite this uh this fan base back up
for maybe another run well I think
they're pretty
ignited well here you go you can work
the mic too
folks um yeah I mean honestly we we had
a tough start to the year but I I felt
like you know um across the board we
felt like we were playing pretty good
games and um it just wasn't going our
way and now uh you know things have been
going our way the last little bit here
we've been playing awesome and and
that's you know credit to the guys in
the room and our coaching staff and um
we've been playing awesome and it's it's
uh yeah it's been a lot of fun this
around here Joey I'm an upcoming free
agent sell me on what it's like to be a
Seattle krack I mean the people here
have been unbelievable we've been here
for a couple days now it's definitely a
hockey crowd if I'm looking to sign here
in Seattle be a part of the Kraken give
me some of the the bonuses of playing
here in Seattle and what it's like I
mean the bonuses for sure is just a fan
base that's the biggest thing um they're
unbelievable they're definitely loud and
you know I've been to Seahawks games
I've been to MLS games I've been to
baseball games um you know you name it
at ubb um been to all the games and and
the the sports fans here are
unbelievable and um you you won't get
supported like this anywhere else well
if you get a chance tomorrow make sure
in your video meeting the coaches put in
there Biz fighting the masc yes yeah
there's a there's a chance he might be
arrested before this segment's over so
it's be the last we see of Biz the last
time I saw Biz he was uh walking through
our locker room at ASU in between
periods to go to the
bathroom I don't know how I don't know
how we pulled that off it the only time
onid mid game crunch to give you guys a
little luck yeah I like I was waiting in
between periods I you see Biz walk
through the the middle of the locker did
a double tap oh I have to ask you cuz
you mentioned uh all the people that it
took for you to get to this point uh
your father goalie goalie coach um what
do you think this means for your family
and also did you have any choice was it
goalie or or or did you fight that at
all at any point um yeah I mean first
off I'm I'm incredibly fortunate to have
such an amazing family and um you know
my dad has been um my mentor my whole
life and and he's been um you know he's
played it inanely huge role in my in my
whole life and career um you know I'm
super super grateful for him and um all
he's that all he's contributed to my
life and my career you know it just kind
of brings into perspective um you know
how special it all is and just to have
him here tonight and um you know we'll
never forget today that's awesome well
he can help you carry this out because
you are the first ever winner of
Joy
Jo the Winter Classic MVP P you playing
outside eat some hot cocoa and you get
the trophy right here MVP do I get some
Coco where is it go make me
some getting pigeon toss oh man he's
making a run for Mr TNT now I know put
him at the top of the list there Jesus
can you join us the rest of the
broadcast shut my mic off well Joey
listen man we really appreciate it
congrats
again let's hear one more time Joey de
cour thank you guys so much what a
special moment